12 11 10 9 good evening and welcome to
the wonderful world of chemistry a magic
show
I'm Neil a hasari I'm from Australia
that's why I sound funny and it is our
pleasure to captivate you tonight with a
series of chemistry demonstrations and
also to explain some basic concepts of
the discipline that we love to you now
this show comes with the demon comes
with a warning what you see tonight
should not be repeated at home the
people doing these demonstrations are
trained experts they have spent years
practicing for tonight so who are these
people where if they come from if we're
going to introduce the team we of course
need some music
so first from Massachusetts
he loves lawn games he loves the
Patriots he is David Charbonneau from
New Jersey
she loves colors she loves running she
loves to talk Julia Curley from Toledo
he plays the mellifont on his birthday
he likes to read a book by himself
Nicholas Smith from Florida she loves
her pet bunny more than anything else in
the world
Emily bath also from Florida he's fluent
in Spanish his pet cat loves to play
with Emily's pet bunny Matthew Espinosa
and finally ladies and gentlemen we have
a star with us tonight
a person who has captivated thousands of
Yale undergrads with his demonstrations
UC chemists are not very famous which is
a shame but if this man was a basketball
player he would be LeBron James if he
was a movie star
he would be Bradley Cooper would you
please welcome the one and only
professor Patrick L Holland
[Applause]
okay so you are here today to learn
about chemistry so first we have to tell
you what chemistry is so chemistry
investigates the composition properties
and behavior of matter so of all of
those words matter
might be one that you are not familiar
with what is matter matter is anything
that occupies space and has mass look
around you touch things pretty much
everything you can see and feel meets
that definition Dave is matter
the walls are matter the chairs are
matter and what is this matter made of
so it's made of very small particles
which are known as atoms atoms are so
small that you can't see them now if we
think about how we construct words we
construct words from letters now we
construct matter using atoms but we have
a lot of different atoms to play with in
fact we have a hundred and eighteen
different atoms which are known as the
elements and these elements
have different properties because they
have a different number of protons
neutrons and electrons now to do our
first demonstration where we see the
different properties of the elements
please welcome professor Holland
excellent welcome everyone and I am
going to show you one of the ways the
chemists have of getting different
elements to reveal themselves oh do you
need to let's let's help help safety is
the most important thing in chemistry
and so yeah okay all right great
all right so we're going to look at one
of the ways that chemists get elements
to reveal themselves and we can tell
what different elements are and that's
because if you heat them up to a high
temperature different elements produce
different colors and if we want to make
them go to a high temperature and
produce those colors how might we go
about that yes so we have a very good
way of doing that here and and what I'm
going to do is I have these samples of
different elements and you can make a
guess at what color it's going to turn
but in order to do this effectively we
need to have some mood music and some
mood lighting
good enough alright so this one is
strontium see if you can guess what
color this is gonna be or whether this
my lighter is gonna work okay ready
so that makes a red color this one has
sodium what color you think it might be
oh let's see
let's see that one makes a orange and
here I have potassium what color oh I
heard a purple that's pretty close - how
about this
now this is actually what people use in
fireworks so these are some of the
vibrant colors that we get in fireworks
for example lithium makes a really
awesome color that you've seen in
fireworks before
this one is barium it makes a different
color that you see in fireworks and
finally copper makes a different color I
think I heard it so the next time you go
see some fireworks this is the way it
works is that there are different
elements in there okay great thank you
so elements have different properties
and we know that chemistry is the study
of matter why is it important to study
chemistry let's have a look at where
chemistry is it's in pharmaceuticals if
you have solar panels on your roof
chemistry is responsible for the
fundamental principles of those solar
panels if you're like me and you play
with a rubber duckie in the bath that's
only possible because of chemistry
paints cosmetics plastics your iPhones
all of the things that we use on an
everyday basis are derived from
chemistry but I want to give you one
more reason why chemistry is important
does anyone in here like movies almost
almost everyone and when you're watching
movies one of the things we'd like are
special effects and chemistry is
responsible for some of the special
effects in the movies let's have a look
at this
so here we have a man on fire you might
be interested in how the chemistry of
this works let's introduce Dave to give
you an explanation about this so the
chemistry is indeed everywhere in our
daily lives and it's my privilege today
to be able to show you guys how
Hollywood producers use chemistry for
their special effects to make it appear
as though one of their actors was on
fire so their actor just appeared to be
on fire that was not done in one take
and the actor was not disposed of so I
asked several of my lab mates if they
would volunteer to help me with this
demonstration and not so shockingly they
all said they did not trust me to set
them on fire
a smart move on their part perhaps but I
am so confident that what I'm about to
do will work that I'm willing to put my
own money on the line literally so I
will put my own money out and set it on
fire
nealy I forgot the money should I trust
him where do you work
what do you what do you think who thinks
I should trust him with a $1 bill come
on
who thinks I should trust him with a $20
bill $20 bilities all right so I am so
confident that this will work that I
will set someone else's money on fire
so what I have in front of me is two
solutions one of which is ethanol
ethanol is a flammable liquid if you
expose it to a flame it will set on fire
I also have a graduated cylinder of
water as we all know water will put out
a flame and if you expose it to a flame
it will not ignite like ethanol will so
if I am able to combine water and
ethanol in the right proportions and
let's see how steady my hand is here
great
I can then soak this dollar bill in the
water ethanol mixture Dave it's a $20
bill and it's mine
not a problem
so I can then soak this $20 bill in this
water ethanol mixture and I can ask my
assistant Matt Espinosa
to come over here and light this on fire
I'd like to point out that since I'm not
the one lighting it on fire I have no
responsibility
if we burn this $20 bill all right here
goes nothing anyway I burned your money
but just a little thank you Dave
okay so we just learnt about the
elements with professor Holland and the
elements are the building blocks it's
like if we want to make letters sorry if
we want to make words we use letters in
chemistry we might want to make
molecules and to make molecules we link
different atoms or elements so what's an
example about this one molecule that's
in the news a lot at the moment is
carbon dioxide carbon dioxide has one
carbon atom and two oxygen atoms water
has one oxygen atom and two hydrogen
atoms methane which you will see later
in the show has four hydrogen atoms and
one carbon atoms now we know with words
we can have simple words and we can have
more complex words these are all
examples of simple molecules let's have
a look at the structure of some more
complicated molecules on the Left we
have caffeine kids this is what makes
your parents get through the day
and in caffeine we have a carbon atom
lots of carbon atoms some nitrogen atoms
some oxygen atoms and then on the right
we have penicillin penicillin is an
antibiotic if you are unfortunate enough
to get a bacterial infection you might
be treated with penicillin and this has
a sulphur atom so many hydrogen atoms
and carbon atoms and the links between
different atoms are known as bonds so
carbon dioxide has a bond between a
carbon atom and an oxygen atom now let
me ask you a question does anyone know
what this molecule is all right someone
has their hand up here ascorbic acid
that is a good guess but it's korvac
acid has a little bit of a simpler
structure any other guesses party
glucose that is a very good guess also
one of the components of this molecule
is glucose the other component is
fructose and that gives us sucrose or
sugar which we all know and love and so
sugar is in candy I wasn't quite sure
who told me our COO COEs but here is
some candy
[Music]
[Applause]
and just like different elements have
different properties different molecules
have different properties and to show
you that emily is going to do a
demonstration Thank You Neely so I on
our atoms or groups of atoms that have a
charge so in these three test tubes in
front of me I have a solution that's
made of ions and I'm going to drop in
some metal salts that are also made of
ions and when I do that the ions in the
solution and the ions in the metal salts
are going to change places and we'll see
some magic happen
so this experiment is called a chemical
garden because you can see it grow like
a plant
so some of you might have gardens at
home or be familiar with gardening but
you've maybe never seen a chemical
garden before so guys if you look at the
first chemical garden that Emily
prepared you can see it's really
starting to sprout and if we be patient
we're going to see the other ones sprout
but before we do that does anyone in
this room remember that I gave Dave a
$20 bill what happened to that $20 bill
I never got it back where's the bill
Dave he burnt it
Emily how's that garden going it looks
like it's growing great to me looks like
it's going great to you so what we're
gonna do is at the end of this show
we're gonna check back in on this garden
and have a look at how much it's grown
okay
so right now especially earlier this
week it was really really cold outside
and when it was cold all of the water
had turned to ice and what we have is
different atoms or different molecules
have different phases so when we have
water in the form of ice it's a solid
when we warm up water it becomes a
liquid and it's even possible to convert
liquid water into a gas if we heat it up
further so if you go past a factory you
see steam which is gaseous water being
emitted from the towers now it turns out
that all different elements and
molecules can exist in these three
phases and to show us something much
more dramatic we're going to see Dave
who owes me $20 come back
hi I'm the one that burned Nia's money
before so as new I mentioned different
materials can exist in different states
of matter and today I'm going to show
you guys sort of an atypical
demonstration of different states of
matter so when I say nitrogen typically
you'll think of a gas this gas composes
75% of our atmosphere
however if you cool nitrogen down to a
low enough temperature you can actually
get nitrogen to be a liquid now you'll
see this smoking a bit this nitrogen is
very cold does anyone know what
temperature water freezes at someone
just shout it out let's hear it
yeah 32 32 you guys got it 32 degrees
Fahrenheit now can anyone guess what
temperature this liquid nitrogen is that
Julia just poured let's hear someone
yell it out lower
negative 300 degrees Fahrenheit yeah so
we also know the temperature of boiling
water right someone yell it out for me
in Fahrenheit what is it
212 degrees Fahrenheit
so that makes a difference of about 500
degrees Fahrenheit between these two
materials boiling water and liquid
nitrogen if I were to add nearly boiling
water to this liquid nitrogen what would
happen is the nitrogen would rapidly
warm up and become a gas and so I'm
gonna do that demonstration for you guys
but first you may notice that these
seats are empty this is the reason sorry
this is a reason
better now Julia may please have the hot
water so you can see it steaming pour it
off
you dog all right all right someone give
me a countdown three two one
[Applause]
yeah I'm gonna just get this kind of
attitude it's a lot of water though so
it'll it'll melt yeah okay would you
mind just me what do you think what do
you think guys should I let Dave keep my
20 bucks after that all right so we've
talked about matter okay and it turns
out that all matter has mass all atoms
have mass and all elements have mass so
let me ask you a question what weighs
more one feather or one brick one brick
okay and just like this kind of matter
has different mass atoms and elements
have different masses okay so why does
one feather weigh less than Wondrich
it's because of density and density is
the mass per unit volume so the brick is
very heavy in a very small volume while
the feather is very light in a large
volume let me ask you a question do
people think that gasses have density
yes or no
so we're scientists so we don't like to
take anyone's word for things we want to
do experiments and demonstrations so
please welcome back professor Holland
and map to show you where the gasses
have density
excellent can we get the lights back up
on us thank you
all right so like you just heard from
Professor Hazara we like to have
experimental tests of whether these
gases have different densities and we
have a couple of different gases here
and we can test this in two different
ways one of them is to see whether the
same volume of this gas weighs more than
air or less than air and we can do that
by say taking some of it and seeing
whether it floats or not so this one
o-line looks like it floats what do you
think this gas might be helium that's
right well it could have been its helium
actually got a different gas I wonder if
mine will float what does everyone think
Samantha's gas is heavier than air so
that's one way that we can test it but
there's a more fun way that we can test
it as well which is because different
densities of gases make the speed of
sound different and so that if
influences the pitch of what we hear and
you might have seen this with helium
maybe we can share a little bit of okay
we can we can try out a little bit of
helium and see what it does to the pitch
of our voices what do you what do you
think that I think it works I think it
works
Nilay sounds like this all the time
we have to breathe helium to do it
alright so this other gas that is well
okay this is this is so fun and we still
have a balloon left you never know what
might happen so we have a second gas
here whoa my voice isn't quite back yet
so what do you think is gonna happen
with the gas that's heavier than air oh
let's find out
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now guys please remember you cannot do
this at home
no inhaling of helium no inhaling as ss6
so so far what we've seen are perhaps
the least exciting parts of chemistry to
me the most empowered of chemistry is
when chemical reactions occur this is
when you take two substances we can call
them a and B and they might form new
substances which we can call C and D so
some of us when we go out in the Sun our
skin burns that is a chemical reaction
let's have a look at a generic chemical
reaction written out in terms of the
molecules involved here we have one
molecule of hydrogen there are two
hydrogen atoms here reacting with half
an equivalent of oxygen which has two
oxygen atoms in ER to make water which
has two hydrogen atoms and one water
molecule and this might be important in
cars of the future which instead of
operating of gasoline will operate off
hydrogen gas when we cook we are doing a
chemical reaction chemical reactions are
crucial to our everyday existence now
one other reason that chemical reactions
are extremely exciting is because
they're often very good to look at let's
welcome Emily back to show us a very
distinct chemical reaction thank you me
late so when we do a chemical reaction
because atoms and molecules are so tiny
we can't always observe directly what's
going on and what molecules we have in
solution so
one way that we can do that is by using
something called an indicator which
usually changes color when a certain
compound is present so in the beaker up
here I have a source of iodine and
starch is an indicator for iodine so if
I add in a starch compound nothing
happens but the magic happens when we
add a solution of hydrogen peroxide so
this reaction is called an oscillating
reaction because it will keep changing
color like this on its own for about
five minutes
[Applause]
okay
so you can keep looking at this reaction
while I'm talking
but chemical reactions are very
important in energy systems an energy is
obviously crucial okay to get here most
of you would have taken a car we needed
gasoline to fuel the car right now we
need to heat our homes that requires
energy and the main forms of energy that
we as a society use at the moment our
oil natural gas and coal all of these
when we burn them release co2 or carbon
dioxide which we know is Dilla tereus
for the environment what we would like
to do as we move forward is use more
renewable forms of energy such as wind
biofuels or solar energy which will have
less are bad consequences for the
environment but let's talk a little bit
more about how we generate energy from
either oil natural gas or coal or these
renewable sources so when we're burning
oil
methane natural gas what we're doing is
we're doing a combustion reaction which
you all know better as fire and when you
stand next to the fire at a campsite you
get heat released and it warms you up so
here is the chemical equation for when
you burn methane and methane is the
primary component of natural gas which
most of you will use to power or heat
your homes so we have one molecule of
methane so you have a carbon with four
hydrogen atoms to molecules of oxygen
react to make carbon dioxide which is
bad for the environment and two
molecules of water
why is
energy released when you do this
combustion reaction it's because the
bonds remember the bonds are the links
between the atoms contain more energy in
the molecules on the left-hand side of
the slide then the molecules that are on
the right-hand side of this slide as a
consequence we release energy when we do
this reaction now does anyone want to
see us do a combustion reaction let's
welcome back professor Holland and Matt
to show us their favorite combustion
reaction I promise I won't burn any more
money so as professor has already
mentioned combustion reactions release a
lot of energy in the form of heat so
what we're gonna be doing for this
demonstration is capturing methane and
bubbles and I'm gonna place them in my
hand and light them on fire so there's
gonna release a lot of heat and I'd
prefer to keep my hands and keep them
not burnt so does it have anyone have
any ideas on how I can protect my hands
gloves are a good suggestion
any others anybody but Dave yeah I just
called it out fake hands yeah I wish I
had those I don't though water I hear
water in the background right
so water who said water will give you
some chocolate and we have some water so
water is very good at capturing heat and
so I'm going to go ahead and grab some
of these bubbles
does anyone think we can get bigger I
agree
go big or go home I got this here we go
thank you very much everyone so heat is
one form of energy another form of
energy is light and we are all exposed
to light energy through the Sun right it
hates us up it keeps us warm
now just like some chemical reactions
can release heat some chemical reactions
release energy in the form of visible
light and I told you earlier that one of
Julia's favorite things was colors we're
going to welcome her back to show us a
demonstration which releases a lot of
light energy thanks Neil a
all right so like Neal a said I
absolutely love colors and I especially
like bright colors so I'm going to talk
today about a compound called luminol
and luminol has a property called
chemiluminescence chemiluminescence
sounds like a fancy word but all it
really means is that when you mix it
with the right chemicals it produces a
nice glow and this demonstration would
work a lot better with some mood
lighting please great thank you
all right so I have two flasks one in
each of my hands and I'm going to pour
them down this spiral tube and as you
can see as soon as the two liquids mix
they start to glow this process is the
same thing that makes glow sticks glow
if you've ever used them on the fourth
of July or at parties and it's the same
thing that makes some type of jellyfish
glow in the water as well and it's one
of my favorite reactions Julia what if I
left my blood everywhere what would
happen you would probably want to go to
the hospital anyway but if you've ever
watched a crime-scene TV show luminol
can be used to find blood at different
crime scenes and it when it reacts with
the blood it actually glows so if you've
ever seen on TV people trying to track
somebody using their blood that's using
luminol
[Applause]
okay so when we have energy in the form
of light or energy in the form of heat
it's very easy for us to touch it to see
it to feel it but not all forms of
energy are so easy to detect so when we
have radioactive materials it's often
hard to tell if a material is
radioactive now fortunately we need a
certain amount of radiation in order for
a material to be dangerous nevertheless
we need a way to measure how much
radiation an object is producing and to
show us how we measure the amount of
radiation that is released please
welcome back professor Holland
excellent yes like Professor hasari said
this is one more example of how chemists
do measurements so that we can
understand what's going on and the way
that we measure radioactivity is using
this does anyone know what it's called
yeah it's a Geiger counter exactly we
said Geiger counter oh absolutely good
work
so there's what's interesting about
radioactivity is there's a little bit
all the time there's some coming from
the Sun there's some coming from some
pretty common materials that are around
us all the time and some that you might
not guess
for example natural potassium has a
little bit of radioactivity and so let's
see we have here it's called no salt
it's people who have high blood pressure
and need to cut down their amount of
sodium they can use potassium chloride
instead so it's a salt replacement you
can buy this at the store and if we pour
some of it in this you can hear yourself
whether there's any radioactivity so you
can buy radioactive things at the store
believe it or not but not very
radioactive luckily we all know that
bananas are rich in potassium what do
you think no no we know that bananas are
rich in potassium relative to other
foods but they're not completely made of
potassium so your bananas bananas not
very radioactive now there are other
things around that you that you take for
granted for example the your silverware
and your the bowls that you use bowls
are made of clay and they have a tiny
bit which you can detect a little bit
there but they used to use glazing on
certain bowls to make them nice and
brightly-colored that had uranium in it
and so this is a 1930s that you could
buy bowls like these and we have some
that are well maybe maybe not the best
thing to be using at home okay so I hope
that I've sort of let you know that this
is one of the things that as we learn
more over time from chemistry and we
learn how to detect things we learn how
to make ourselves safer and you know and
eliminate products that are bad for us
okay all right that's what I want to
tell you about okay so we've seen a
number of examples of chemical reactions
so far tonight when we are starting a
chemical reaction it almost always
requires some kind of input of energy
there are a variety of ways that we can
put in this energy does anyone know what
the most common ways here heating that's
right so when we're cooking we're doing
chemical reactions right that's why our
egg changes when we put it on the stove
and what is driving or starting that
chemical reaction is he there are other
chemical reactions which Julia in
particular likes which are initiated by
white and in that case we have energy
being put in in the form of light now
Nick is going to show us a chemical
reaction which starts with heat but it's
a special chemical reaction which I'm
going to let him tell us about hi there
everybody so I have here a block of dry
ice in fact a couple of blocks of dry
ice and what I've done is inside of the
dry ice I have placed a little bit
magnesium magnesium is a metal which is
a little special in that it burns at
over 4,000 degrees Fahrenheit so what
we're going to do is we're going to
react it with the dry ice dry ice is
carbon dioxide that's been cooled down
and is a solid so I'm going to turn on
this ventilation here sorry about that
the problem is that as the as the carbon
dioxide cools down the metal it very
quickly evaporates and turns back into a
gas and then it makes that sound so what
I'm going to do here is provide a little
bit of input energy to this reaction
using this a blowtorch and we will see
what happens
and there you have it the magnesium has
reacted with the carbon dioxide and has
formed carbon as well as magnesium oxide
[Applause]
okay so we can stop chemical reactions
with heat but sometimes we don't want to
have to put in a large amount of heat to
start a reaction heat takes energy where
do we get that heat from it's not always
possible so what we can do is we can
find what is known as a catalyst and a
catalyst can lower the amount of energy
it takes to start a reaction so how does
it work
a catalyst is essentially a substance
that will change the rate of reaction
without being consumed in the reaction
so that's even more cool we put it in it
does the chemical reaction and we get it
back at the end of the reaction now does
anyone in this room have a water bottle
with them yes okay so I don't think
that's a plastic water bottle though
correct yes it is a plastic water bottle
okay so that plastic water bottle was
almost certainly made using a catalyst
and the catalyst that was used to make
that water bottle was probably a
zirconium complex and the zirconium
complex is such an efficient catalyst
that if we have one gram of the
zirconium catalyst we will make a
million grams of the plastic and the
catalyst is so good that we don't even
remove the zirconium from the plastic
because that level of zirconium in that
amount of plastic doesn't cause a hazard
to anyone so what we have is we have a
slow reaction or no reaction where we
have two molecules a plus B they look at
each other they don't do anything they
won't go to C or D it might take 500
years a million years for that process
to happen we add a catalyst and we get a
fast reaction sometimes instantaneous
at room temperature 90% of commercial
products that are available are made
using catalysts so these things that we
had on our earlier slides
pharmaceuticals detergents cosmetics are
all made using catalysts now I think
we're going to welcome back Nick and
Julia who are going to do a
demonstration which illustrates what a
catalyst can do all right thank you
Neela so now that Neely has introduced
you to what a catalyst is we're going to
show you a little bit of a demonstration
so have any of you ever thought to
yourself how does an elephant brush his
teeth you use toothpaste well an
elephant would obviously need a very
large amount of toothpaste so what we
have here is four flasks each of them
have some hydrogen peroxide in them and
what happens when hydrogen peroxide a
very unstable chemical falls apart is it
produces a lot of oxygen gas and water
vapor now that happens by itself rather
slowly so what we're going to do is
we're going to add in a catalyst to each
of these just to speed up the reaction
and of course we've added some soap to
it to catch the bubbles that way we're
able to provide something for those
elephants to brush their teeth with so
Julia is going to help me sense let me
double check yep I only have two arms
not four so on the count of three all
right one two three there we go and now
the elephants can brush their teeth
[Applause]
all right so we hope that you've had a
wonderful time tonight but tonight is
just an introduction to chemistry over
the course of the year through the
pathways program which Maria Allison and
Claudia run you will have many
opportunities to participate in
chemistry outreach events you might be
able to learn about a specific area of
chemistry today you've learned all about
the general principles of chemistry but
you might learn about organic chemistry
which is particularly relevant to
synthesizing pharmaceuticals
you might learn about inorganic
chemistry which is more relevant to
making plastics or large scale products
if you were completely scared with what
we did tonight you might want to be a
theoretical chemist and then you can
just think about things maybe you're
interested in how the body works if you
study biochemistry you will learn about
that and you should look for the
pathways emails to see more details
[Applause]
the garden
hit Auto versus hot opal
now before we do one last demonstration
for you I've been told that you all
entered your names into a raffle so we
are now going to draw that raffle Matt
could you please pull out a name from
here so Matt has pulled out a name
before we announced that I should tell
you that the prize is $100 gift
certificate to the Connecticut Science
Center so it's not as cool as what you
saw tonight but it's really pretty
fantastic and you'll notice that we
didn't give this gift certificate to
Dave to burn so our winner of the gift
certificate is Fatma nor aikka
and I apologize if I pronounced that
wrong from Bayley Middle School in West
Haven our congratulations I'm going to
give
[Applause]
okay so
from all of us thank you very much for
coming tonight
and before you leave we're going to show
you one last demonstration for all times
when we we show you how chemists reveal
things and Matt has made something very
special here that will be revealed is
this the front okay and you can see it
doesn't say anything what's wrong oh we
need some we need some chemistry here oh
my gosh that's really long okay we need
to we need to reveal this and in order
to reveal this we need we need the whole
team here and so I'd like you to give
one last hand for each of our people and
and I'm going to give each of them one
of our weapons that we can use to reveal
the message on this okay so a big hand
for Emily Barth the man for Julia Curley
Nick Smith
James Charbonneau
and and of course our ringleader and
master here professor Neil a his eye and
oh and Matt Matt Espinosa my partner in
crime
alright let's see it go for it
trying to distance I need help guys
alright thanks for coming everyone
[Applause]
you
[Music]